the biden administration considers a new
masked push even for the vaccinated my
answer
is no i'm ben shapiro this is the bench
bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressvpn.com
ben well if you ever take a look at your
monthly bills you may have noticed
you're paying way too much money for
your cell phone
provider how do i know you're paying too
much money well if you're with anybody
other than pure talk usa you're paying
too much money
take a look at that cell phone bill if
you're with verizon a t or t-mobile
you're paying too much because pure talk
could be saving your family over 800
dollars a year same great coverage
because pure talk is on the exact same
network as one of the big three but at a
fraction of the price
and switching is as easy as switching
out your sim card you can keep your
phone keep your number or get huge
discounts
on the latest iphones and androids plus
right now get unlimited talk text six
gigs of data for just 30 bucks a month
and
if you go over on the data they're not
going to charge you for it there's a
reason pure talk is the highest rated
wireless company
by consumer affairs why they are the
preferred wireless partner of
amac from your cell phone i'll pound 250
right now say ben
shapiro save an additional 50 off your
very first month that is pound 250
say my name ben shapiro to get started
save an additional fifty percent
off your very first month your phone
company is probably fibbing to you
they're not going to give you the full
story on why exactly you're paying what
you're paying
bottom line you're paying way too much
go check out pure talk usa right now
dial pound 250
say ben shapiro save an additional 50
off your very first month
of coverage alrighty so we are seeing a
new push
in the media among the intelligentsia
for re-masking
remasking is the thing right now for the
vaccinated and for the unvaccinated
and this frankly is unsupportable it is
not supportable by the evidence
the reason that it is unsupportable by
the evidence is because the reality is
that we do have a pandemic that
continues to harm people
if you are unvaccinated if you are
vaccinated however then
this thing really is no longer of
serious concern to you
it is not particularly dangerous to you
and we are seeing this in the statistics
so for example here is a chart
from the united kingdom okay this chart
from the united kingdom
shows a large scale difference between
the second wave and the third wave
what it shows is cases versus deaths
over days one through 50
of the uk's second and third coveted
waves now typically what happens with
regards to these covered waves is that
you have a wave of diagnoses
and then about two weeks later you have
a wave of death because it takes people
a little while to die from covet okay so
during the second wave
for example you can see cases versus
deaths over days 1 through 50
of the of the second wave you saw that
on day one
there were 3.3 cases per 100 000
population
and then there was 1.5 death per 10
million population
by day 50 had about 33 cases per 100
000 population in britain and 36 deaths
per 10 million population okay so you
see the
the cases and the deaths start to mirror
each other fairly quickly
and now take a look at these stats from
the third wave meaning after there's
been a mass vaccination
in the united kingdom and what you see
is that at the beginning it looks kind
of similar
we have 3.4 cases per 100 thousand
population and 1.3 deaths per 10 million
population and then as the cases
exponentially increase
the deaths continue to be extremely low
right so by the end when you get to day
reminder in the second wave day 50 had
33 cases per 100 000 population and 36
deaths
per 100 per 10 million population in the
third wave
you have 30 33 cases same thing 33.6
cases
per 100 000 population and 2.1 deaths
per 10 million population
in other words we have cut down on the
death rate in great britain
by about 12-fold and which takes this
thing down below the rate of death from
the flu
and the reason for that is because the
people who now are getting this
tend to be younger tend to be healthier
people who are older
have gotten mass vaccinated this is true
in every industrialized country in which
vaccination has taken place people who
are older and more vulnerable have taken
the vaccine
we have people in our office who have
not taken the vaccine the reason they
usually give is because one they
think that they already had covet or
they were tested they already had
coveted so they think they have natural
immunity
or two and usually both two they're very
young
and so they tend to look around and say
okay i'm 21 years old my chances of
dying from this thing are not
particularly high
okay so even if they get it they're
really not dying from it not nearly in
the same numbers that people were dying
before
now in absolute numbers could you see a
lot of death among people who are young
sure because the delta variant is
significantly more transmissible
than the original variant than the wild
type variant the wild type variant
was transmissible the r was something
like two or three
the r meaning the reproduction rate on
this thing is like six meaning that
basically if you're if you're a human
being you have two choices right now
any human being you have two choices one
you get the vaccine
or two you can get covered you are going
to get immunity one way or the other
okay so that is up to you because you're
a free independent human being and
again we've done a pretty tremendous job
in the west of making sure that people
who are the most vulnerable
have already had the vaccine there are
people now who are thinking about
vaccinating
who weren't vaccinating before because
people react rationally
to risk reward calculations and this is
what the data show
okay so there's an article today in abc
news about a large-scale increase
of cases hospitalizations being seen
in for example northeastern florida
according to abc news you have health
jacksonville
in florida's most populous city has seen
an exponential rise in the number of
covenant 19 patients admitted in recent
weeks according to chad nielsen director
of infection prevention
at the hospital the previous record for
the highest number of daily covet 19
patients across both of its campuses
125.
was set in january the hospital
currently has 136 people who are
hospitalized
about 40 people in the icu last week
there were 75 coveted patients in the
hospital 45 the week before and 20 the
week
before that according to nielsen we knew
it was most likely due to the delta
variant taking a bigger footprint here
in the northeastern florida region
because it was so rapid of an increase
everyone in town is suffering the same
fate
that we are at the mayo clinic's
jacksonville hospital there's been a
significant increase in cover 19
hospitalizations
over the past three weeks approaching
our previous peak number since dr ken
thielen
ceo of mayo clinic in florida said this
is a five-fold increase in covet
hospitalizations and follows many weeks
when we only had a handful of
hospitalized
coveted patients but here is the here
are the stats that matter are you ready
among uf health jacksonville's cover 19
patients
90 are unvaccinated 90
are unvaccinated in other words the
number of people who are getting the
vaccines
and then they're having a breakthrough
infection is very low and the number of
people who are getting hospitalized is
really really really low
and the number of people who are dying
after being vaccinated is super duper
duper low
however if you're unvaccinated the
disease treats you the same way that it
would have treated you back in january
or back in november or back in the
in the in the prior march we have better
ways of treating you now and we've
figured out for example that we're not
going to vent you we figured out that
we're not going to put you on your back
but you are still facing a very similar
level of risk
to what you are facing in january even
though it is now july you're facing a
very similar level of risk if you are
unvaccinated the same way you were in
january
the virus has changed a little bit but
it hasn't changed in its deadliness it's
only changed in its transmissibility
according to thomas van ostell the
president and ceo of ascension florida
and gulf coast which operates a hospital
in jacksonville over 96 percent
of its covenant 19 patients are
unvaccinated he says our median age of
hospitalized patients is 49.
it was in the mid-60s in prior waves of
the pandemic it's a younger demographic
we're not getting vaccinated
unfortunately they're contracting covet
these cases are requiring
hospitalization for treatment now
also the rates of death after
hospitalization are way down
from what they were at the beginning of
the pandemic at the beginning of the
pandemic if you went to the hospital
there's a
pretty decent shot that you were going
to die now if you go to the hospital
less of a shot that you're going to die
the movement from hospitalization to icu
to death
is is a lot more attenuated at baptist
health in jacksonville the covenant 19
patients are younger
sicker and getting sicker quickly said
chief medical officer dr timothy groover
in the past month 44 of cover 19
patients at the hospital were in their
40s or younger
most were previously healthy
so what this means is that people are
sort of ramping up vaccinations they're
thinking more seriously about
vaccinations but again
what the stats show is that we have
basically disconnected the case rate
from the death rate
meaning that we're seeing lots and lots
and lots of cases and not an awful lot
of death
there's another chart from the uk that
demonstrates this full scale you can see
it right here
on this chart okay this chart right here
shows
that you're you can see the waves follow
each other right you can see the wave of
death
and you can see the wave of of covid the
coveted wave comes
very quickly thereafter the deaths come
and they charge each other really
really smoothly and then now you see a
massive
increase in the number of coveted cases
and you don't see the death the death
just isn't happening in the same way
again because we have done a very good
job in the west of vaccinating the
elderly
and so younger people are getting this
thing not older people
people who are less vulnerable not
people who are more vulnerable
and so it's important also to take a
look at some of the stats that are being
bandied about
with regard to hospitalization rates for
example so
in florida you're seeing an increase in
hospitalization into the jacksonville
area
that is on par with what we saw in
january but among younger people who are
less likely to die even after being
hospitalized than older people like 65
year olds who are being hospitalized
in january sometimes the headlines are
just completely disconnected from
realities the los angeles times
says california coronavirus
hospitalizations have hit highest point
in months as delta spreads
you have to dig down until paragraph
four before you get to this
even with the recent increase though the
state's healthcare system is nowhere
near as swamped as it was during the
fall and winter surge
many health experts are confident
california will never see numbers on
that scale again
given how many residents are
with the continued spread of the highly
infectious delta variants which
officials fear could mushroom in
communities with lower inoculation rates
the next few weeks are key in
determining how potent the pandemic's
latest punch
may be right okay so bottom line is once
again we're not seeing the same level of
hospitalization as we saw broadly
speaking over the course of countries
we're seeing huge numbers of cases fewer
hospitalizations
many many many fewer deaths because you
are seeing again a disconnect between
the people who are getting this thing
and the people who tend to die
of this thing which means that
realistically speaking many nations are
learning to let it go and live with
kovid which
of course was always going to happen now
there was a case to be made by the way
that even before the advent of the
vaccine
places needed to learn to live with
covet namely you shield the most
vulnerable and you allow everybody else
to go out and work and there's something
that sweden did for example in sweden
was ripped up and down
sweden's excess death rate when you
actually
chart it to their to their age right you
have to actually adjust for age because
you have a population
that's entirely 20 years old versus a
population that's entirely 70 years old
they're not going to have the same death
rates
if you actually chart their excess
mortality rates there have been some
studies done on this
what it suggests is that sweden's excess
mortality rates during the pandemic
over the course of the over the course
of 2020 was an increase
of about 1.5 percent it was actually
significantly higher in germany which
locked down
very wide in fact sweden which was
ripped up and down
for its for its coveted policy now ranks
somewhere around 40th in the world
in terms of death per million from covet
and that's not population adjusted
for age so there is a case to be made
pretty early on
that shield the elderly let everybody
else go out and do what they're going to
do
and if you want a mass mask and you
don't want a mask don't mask that was
not actually a terrible
policy idea especially because what we
are finding out right now is that
natural immunity in some of these cases
may be stronger than vaccine
created immunity that's what some of the
statistics out of israel are tending to
show so if you're 21 years old
everybody was treating as a giant
problem and tragedy if you were 21
in january and getting covered but if
you weren't dying from cova this just
meant you were immune from covet in the
natural way before you could get a
vaccine
so it took one person off the board in
terms of reproducing the virus and
pushing it out to others
but now that the vaccines are available
there's no question that we should be
moving back to a regular life
there really is none because anything
else has no limiting principle
it's the point i keep making over and
over and over once every adult
has had the opportunity to get the
vaccine it is now up to them
the original goal of the lockdowns the
original goal of masking policy
was to prevent people from overwhelming
the hospital system
right that was the entire goal don't let
the hospital systems be overwhelmed with
covered patients so that people don't
die needlessly and so if you flatten the
curve
the area under the curve is going to be
the same over the course of time but
it's going to be
beneath medical capacity so that means
that no one dies without at least
having the treatment that could possibly
save their life right that was the
original goal
we did that we prevented coveted from
swamping the hospitals and overwhelming
the system
and that's what the lockdowns were for
then the goal changed to okay well you
know we do have these vaccines on the
way if we just delay this thing
then maybe if we have lowered the curve
we can actually stop the curve
before it rises again right we can
actually stop the death
through the vaccine so it's a delay
tactic right we're going to lock down a
little bit more we'll mask a little bit
more and this will delay because that's
really all that lockdowns and masking do
they delay the inevitable
because eventually you assume people are
going to take off the masks and stop the
lockdowns and go out of their homes
so the idea now was delay until the
vaccines are available then
vaccines became widely available now
as i keep saying over and over there's
no end goal there's no end goal
right the the notion that we are all
supposed to continue masking forever
even though the vaccines are now
available is asinine
we are going to have to learn to live
with the reality that adults are adults
we're going to have to learn to live
with the reality that if you're
vaccinated you're pretty much safe from
the virus statistically speaking
if you're unvaccinated you're just as
unprotected from the virus as you were
six months ago and so that is up to you
that's now on you that is your decision
and we can't lock down
all of society or ask vaccinated people
to mask on the basis that they might
infect
somebody asymptomatically who refuses to
either mask or to get the vaccine you
can't restrict people because other
people refuse to do
the thing that would protect them we
don't do this with any other form of
disease
and especially when you're talking about
a vaccine that takes the rates of death
of this thing
all the way down to below the flu
again if people choose not to make that
decision i think it's a foolish decision
i've said over and over and over on the
program i think that people should
vaccinate
it's funny there are a bunch of articles
the media are intense
i'm trying to blame the right for the
failure of vaccinations
in in certain parts of the country and
some of these media pieces are saying
that i like me specifically that i have
not backed vaccines that's of course
idiotic i backed vaccines since
literally the first day
okay i continue to maintain that getting
a vaccine is a good idea that these mrna
vaccines by all available scientific
evidence
are safe i'm not going to say that
they're safe for children because we
have no longitudinal effects with regard
to that but
what i will say is that the statistics
tend to show that yes
sure there there could be risks from the
vaccine but those risks are below the
risk of dying from covet or getting
seriously ill from covet
with long-lasting covet facts right
particularly for adults
but that's your choice you're a free and
independent human being
that is your choice right now we'll get
to more of this in just one second first
let us talk about a simple fact if
you're a responsible human being
you need to make sure that you have life
insurance i mean you could be walking
along the street and suddenly a train
filled with clowns just
runs you over well everyone would laugh
the reality is that not only would it be
sad for your family you would also not
have provided for them unless you have
life insurance
make sure that you have life insurance
in case you suffer a cartoonish death
make sure that your family is taken care
of you can save 50
or more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius
they make it easy to compare quotes from
over a dozen top insurers all in one
place which could save you 1300 bucks or
more
per year on life insurance by using
policy genius to compare policies
the licensed experts at policy genius
work for you not the insurance companies
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process
that kind of service has earned policy
genius thousands of five-star reviews
across
trustpilot and google and eligible
applicants can get covered in as little
as a week
thanks to an award-winning policy option
that swaps the standard medical exam
requirement for a simple phone call that
exclusive policy was recently rated
number one by forbes higher than options
from ladder
ethos and bestow getting started is
super simple head on over to policy
geniuses.com
shapiro you can work out how much life
insurance coverage you need compared to
those personalized quotes find your best
price and when you're ready to apply
policy genius will handle the paperwork
and scheduling for free head on over to
policygenius.com gets started right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and quite important
to get it right so as i speak i'm
looking at the covet death statistics
in the united states this is via the new
york times last update about 13 hours
ago
the seven day average of deaths from
covet in the united states despite this
massive
increase in cases in the united states
remains at 249.
249 as i mentioned this means that
kovid is now not among the top causes of
death in the united states on a daily
basis heart disease
cancer even diabetes and alzheimer's
like diabetes is on par with the number
of deaths that we are suffering per day
from covet now coveted is a
transmissible disease obviously
you could have an uptick in death but we
are seeing a
pretty vast disconnect between the
amount of death and the number of cases
that are being diagnosed just as we have
seen in britain
if you go all the way back to march
right february we were having about 60
000 new cases a day in the united states
yesterday we had about 60 000 cases so
we are back to those levels of caseload
but it's different people who are
getting them thanks to the widespread
vaccination
of the elderly so the new york times has
a piece about this
england has removed nearly all
coronavirus restrictions germany is
allowing vaccinated people to travel
without quarantines outdoor mass
mandates are mostly gone in italy
shopping malls remain open in singapore
18 months after the first coronavirus
emerged governments in asia europe and
the americas
are encouraging people to return to
their daily rhythms and transition to a
new normal
in which subways offices restaurants and
airports are once again full
increasingly the mantra is the same we
have to learn to live with the virus now
remember when i said this
last year that we might have to learn to
live with the virus i was ripped up and
down for this how
no no zero cova is a goal zero coveted
was never a realistic goal
ever there was nobody who was a medical
expert last year
except for anthony fauci who was
idiotically out there suggesting that we
were going to crush the curve to the
point where
basically the virus was no longer in
circulation this is a highly
transmissible coronavirus
that is literally present in nearly
every nation on the globe
the notion that you're going to cut this
thing down to zero was always a pipe
dream it was never going to happen
that is not an argument against
vaccination it's an argument in favor of
reality
according to the new york times however
scientists warn that pandemic exit
strategies may be premature
the emergence of more transmissible
variants means even wealthy nations with
abundant vaccines remain vulnerable
places like australia which shut down
its borders are learning they cannot
keep the virus out well if that's the
case then
why exactly are we arguing about
continuing shutdowns and lockdowns and
remasking
officials are beginning to accept that
rolling lockdowns and restrictions are a
necessary part of recovery
people are being encouraged to shift
their pandemic perspective and focus on
avoiding severe
illness and death instead of infections
correct that's right
that's why people should vaccinate not
to avoid getting infected in the first
place to avoid dying
to avoid going to the hospital of course
honestly there's no other disease where
we care about case rate none you don't
care how many people get the flu every
year how many people die from the flu
every year
millions and millions of people get the
common cold every year have you ever
heard that as a public health crisis
requiring masking of course not because
people don't die of the cold
right so the question is death rates
from covered which have been brought
down radically
now again that's because on average
they've been brought down meaning
that there are people who die it's
pretty binary there are people who die
and people who don't and people who die
tend to be unvaccinated and people don't
tend to be vaccinated or have already
had this thing with a level of natural
immunity
dale fisher professor of medicine at the
national university of singapore
who heads the national infection
prevention and control committee of
singapore's health ministry says
you need to tell people we're going to
get a lot of cases and that's part of
the plan we have to let it go
so we're all now we're doing world
sweden right last year it was sweden is
the worst country on planet earth and
rhonda sanchez in florida who pursued a
similar strategy
worst person on earth now it's like well
i guess you know we're just going to
have to do exactly what they did
yeah we know we know
and that's fine thank god we have a
vaccine now that has radically reduced
the death rate that is a that is a gift
from science it's a gift from god like
it is a wonderful wonderful thing
and also you now need to let people live
free because otherwise there are no
limiting principles to anything that you
are talking about
this notion that we are supposed to
continue masking forever and do
shutdowns
forever is just ridiculous i'm sorry
there is no
logical principle that that can be held
consistently it would not also you to
require up
for pneumonia or tuberculosis
or the flu and so the same logic that is
currently being used for
arguments about re-masking particularly
vaccinated people
those arguments masking kids right those
arguments are equally uh applicable to a
wide variety of diseases which really
says the government should have control
until the end of time so right now the
white house naturally is debating
whether to walk back its view on masking
according to the washington post
top white white house aides and biden
administration officials are debating
whether they should urge vaccinated
americans to wear masks in more settings
as the delta variant causes spikes and
coveted infections across the country
according to six people familiar with
the discussions vaccinated americans not
unvaccinated americans again i
understand the argument for unvaccinated
americans to wear a mask if you don't
want to transmit it and you don't want
to get it
then presumably get 95. right 95s are
pretty widely available at this point
but vaccinated americans so i'm supposed
to mask up
despite the fact that i can even though
you have had the ability to protect
yourself
i'm supposed to mask up and mask my kid
so you don't get it even though you're a
free
individual human being but the capacity
to make a decision
according to the washington post the
talks are in a preliminary phase the
result could be as simple as new
messaging from top white house officials
but some of the talks include officials
at the cdc
uh the vaunted cdc which has blown this
every step of the way are separately
examining whether to update their
masking guidance according to a biden
administration aide and a federal health
official
officials cautioned any new formal
guidance would have to come from the cdc
they say the white house has taken a
hands-off approach which of course
is not true at all you'll remember that
the cdc originally
set masking standards in coordination
with the white house and only later said
oh yeah by the way
you can unmask if you're vaccinated the
high level discussions reflect rising
concerns
about the threat of the delta variants
one idea batted around by administration
officials
would be to ask all americans to wear
masks when vaccinated and unvaccinated
people mix
at public places or indoors no
no the answer is no i'm not doing that i
also don't think my kids should be
masked
no if you're an adult and choose not to
get masked it's on you now
end of story truly end of story because
otherwise there's no end to this
otherwise they can do this at any time
for the rest of time for any reason
or no reason we'll get some more of this
in just one second first
i am a pretty busy dude hosting my show
raising three kids they wake me up at
all hours of the night and early
in the morning i have to have a higher
energy level i'm sure you do too that is
why i recommend
mdrive the everyday supplement for men
driven to stay ahead in their life and
career
would love to be the best at what they
do and not slow down while doing it
m drive gives you the energy to tackle
your busy days and still be at your best
when you go home at night
invented by a world-class scientist who
made it for himself to fight back
against aging
m drive is packed with clinically tested
ingredients that help boost your energy
and strength
get your m drive at mdrive4men.com get
off your first order with promo code ben
the jews around the office have been
taking em drive i can see
the drive in their eyes they have free
shipping and a 60-day money-back
guarantee energy
strength drive join the growing
community of driven men who aren't ready
to slow down
go to mdrive4men.com promo code ben
don't let age
beat you refined your prime with m drive
go check them out right now once again
that is
mdrive4men.com use promo code
ben to get 20 off your first order m
mdrive4men.com promo code ben alrighty
so
last night joe biden was on cnn where he
engaged in his usual battles with
the teleprompter again it is it is a
source of constant amusement that the
president of the united states does not
appear to have firing synapses at this
point here's the president of the united
states
and and don lemon trying to bail him out
over and over and uh and
the president basically just wandering
into the cornfield
the question is whether or not we should
be in a position where
you uh um are why can't
the the the experts say
we know that this virus is in fact
uh um uh is it is going to be
uh or assuming we we know why all the
drugs approved are not temporarily
approved
but permanently approved that's underway
too i expect that to occur quickly well
that
means you mean for the fda for the fda
yeah
um i don't know what any of that was
supposed to mean
was that in english it is i mean it's an
amazing country where literally anyone
can be president
i mean they say that america english is
the
there's an argument about whether
english ought to be the official
language no i mean we
we elect presidents routinely in this
country who don't speak english anyway
the president of the united states then
added i don't tell the scientists what
to do which is overtly untrue i mean the
reality is the white house coordinates
with the cdc
they coordinate with all of the quote
unquote health officials
and then they issue guidance that very
much reflects the political priorities
of the administration but here's biden
trying to separate off
from the mandates that are to come
when will children under 12 be able to
get vaccinated soon
i believe now look one of the things
that i committed to do
when i got elected i said i'll soon
assume mr president that ticket well i i
i
let me hear let me finish the question
the answer
soon in the sense that i do not tell
any scientist what they should do
um okay so now he says he's not going to
tell any of the scientists what to do um
yeah i i don't believe you but this is
biden's way of disconnecting from the
fact that he said we were all going to
be free and easy as of july 4th and we
are no longer free and easy
he's now going to say oh well the
scientists told me the scientists told
me except these are political decisions
i've said from the very beginning of
this pandemic these this is not up to
fouchy
it's not up to the scientists we elect
people to balance all of the competing
considerations
and at the beginning this was considered
cruel and terrible if you pointed out
that hundreds of thousands of people
millions of people literally tens of
millions of people actually
lost their jobs during the pandemic then
you were accused of making
light of death if you pointed out there
were very very differential death rates
by by age group and this meant that we
should have 20 year olds working but not
60 year olds working
then this was considered cruel and
inhumane but that is the stuff we elect
people to do we elect people
to take into account all of those
priorities if you're a public health
official your goal is always going to be
zero deaths
and the easiest way to prevent death is
to lock you in your home forever
okay so it is up to the president of the
united states to stop all of that
but the president is not going to stop
all of that the president of the united
states apparently
is just going to allow the scientists to
make public policy
that is not correct they they ought to
have input into public policy but it is
at the political level
when people who are supposed to weigh
all the competing factors make the
policy that's what's supposed to matter
here's biden just abdicating full
responsibility and
suggesting that the cdc is going to tell
kids to wear masks in school remember
the cdc said like a week ago that kids
don't really need to wear masks in
school and kids should be back in school
full time
then the american academy of pediatrics
put out a notice
in coordination by the way with the
t-shirts unions they overtly say that
they are doing this in coordination with
the teachers unions telling you you need
to mask up your three-year-old that's
asinine you don't need to mask up your
three-year-old
i have a seven a five and one i don't
need to mask my five-year-old or my
seven-year-old
the reason i don't need to ask them is
because i'm not afraid of them getting
covered
and i'm not afraid of their classmates
getting coveted and the reason i'm not
particularly afraid of them or their
classmates getting covered is because
the rates of death for people under the
age of 18
in the united states from kovid are so
low they bog
they beggar the imagination and boggle
the mind the total number of people
under the age
of 18 in the united states this is a a
cohort of 75 million human beings in the
united states
in which we've had millions of diagnosed
cases of covet the total number of
deaths
from covid in the united states for
people under the age of t of 18
is below 350 out of 75
million people okay that that does not
be speak the necessity of masking
unless what you're afraid of is that the
kids are going to infect the adults
but if you're afraid the kids are going
to infect the adults we go back to our
original logic
have the adults had the opportunity to
get the vaccine if the answer is yes and
they haven't done it
that is now their problem and if they
have peculiar vulnerabilities that
prevent them from getting the vaccine
then we should get them an n95 we should
have them teach from home
but that's true regardless of what kind
of diseases are circulating there's
always stuff out there that can kill
people
who have peculiar vulnerabilities
health-wise
once you've had the opportunity to have
vaccine it's on you
and masking up my five-year-old to
protect your 40-year-old ass when you
won't get a vaccine
is absurd it's absurd there's no reason
we should be doing it
and if you're worried that those kids
are going to come home and take it to an
adult
then the adults ought to get there's a
very obvious solution here
get vaccinated if you don't want
somebody else infecting you period and
if you don't care about getting
infected you don't care about getting
covered well then
that's on you good on you i mean that's
that's your decision you're a rational
human being but here is job
again the level of top down control the
level of scorn that politicians have for
you
in your decision making is truly an
amazing thing did it ever occur to them
that there are a lot of people
out there who might have reasons that i
disagree with on not getting the vaccine
but reasons that are not just simply i
watch trucker carlson or i love trump
but i'm not getting
there a lot of people who have
rationales that they think
are at least a risk-reward calculation
and they are allowed to make those
risk-reward calculations
let's say that you are 25 years old and
your chances of dying from this virus
are something like six
in ten thousand and you say to yourself
okay well
we haven't had full fda clearance right
we're still working under emergency use
authorization we haven't had full fda
clearance
of the vaccines that say that they are
fully safe
there has been no longitudinal testing
maybe i had covered
already and i'm relying on my own
natural immunity
okay well fine i mean seriously fine
like
i differ from your assessment again i
got the vaccine my wife got the vaccine
my parents got the vaccine
but you are allowed to make that
decision in a free country
but to say that you are allowed to make
that decision in a free country
but that i have to mask because you
might make the wrong decision
is totally nuts or that my kid has to
mask by the way it doesn't have a great
impact on kids i got my kids running
around in 90 degree heat with a mask on
for no reason that i can see here is joe
biden however abdicating his duty to
actually be a leader
the cdc is going to say that what you
should do is
everyone over the age of under the age
of 12
should probably be wearing a mask in
school that's probably what's going to
happen
secondly those over the age of 12 who
are able to get vaccinated if you're
vaccinated
you shouldn't wear a mask if you aren't
vaccinated you should be wearing a mask
so it's going to get a little bit tight
in terms of well
or mom or dad being honest that you know
johnny did or did not get vaccinated
that's going to raise questions
okay well um what if we don't care
whether johnny did or did not get a
vaccine when he's 15 years old
what if that's none of your business
really because
after all he's 15 and the number of
people who are dying
aged 15 from the vaccine really really
really low
really low okay so it's
yeah all of this is is kind of madness
jerome adams who's the surgeon general
under
donald trump he said instead of vaccine
or masket emerging data suggests cdc
should be advising to vaccine and mask
it in areas with high case numbers and
positivity
until we see numbers going back down
again cdc was well intended but the
message was misinterpreted premature and
wrong
let's fix it based on what based on what
again the whole purpose of masking was
to prevent overwhelming of the hospitals
in the absence
of a solution we have a solution if you
choose not to access the solution
i don't understand why i'm supposed to
lead my life the rest of my life
apparently
masking up and covering my face like as
you all know
if you've watched or listened to the
show i was actually a masking advocate
until you get
until you get the vaccines i said the
best available science shows that it
prevents you from spreading the disease
and if you have an n95 prevents you from
getting the disease and i wasn't
anti-masking
now i'm anti-masking for the vaccinated
because what the hell
what is the point of getting the vaccine
if i'm going to have to live the rest of
my life in a mask anyway
is it you're actually creating a
perverse incentive it's amazing all the
public health officials who say that
it's right-wing misinformation that is
leading to lower vaccination rates
there are charts they demonstrate
explicitly that the rates of vaccination
in the united states were rising fairly
precipitously
and then leveling off at a high level
and then you had the johnson johnson
vaccine pause
which was an a moronic idea by the
federal government in which they paused
the distribution of j and j
after seven million doses had gone out
because there were six count them six
cases
of people with a rare blood clotting
disorder and then
people started to get pretty hesitant
about the vaccines right quick and now
you're telling people
that even if they vaccinate they are
still going to have to mask up until the
end of time
because there might be some person down
the road who didn't feel like
vaccinating so you got to protect them
no the answer is no own your decisions
if you're here's the thing people who
are not vaccinated
by and large they are willing to own
those decisions so if they're willing to
own the decisions and i'm willing to own
my decision
what business is this of the federal
government in the first place
and why are you putting on kids that's
the part that's totally wild
yet that is the the new going notion
here is dr jonathan riemer on cnn saying
every kid should be going to school mask
every child from your three-year-old to
your 17 year old should be going to
school mast
every kid going to school should be
masked uh vaccinated or not and i know
this
is this angers uh people who have
been vaccinated but we need to protect
everyone and we really can't tell who's
been vaccinated who hasn't i think every
kid going to school should have a mask
on to protect
those who just have chosen not to be
vaccinated and those who can't be
um really that so this is where we're
going
this is this is where we're going
wonderful
wonderful okay meanwhile the
the biden administration continues to
maintain that the big problem here is
not its own failures of public health
messaging
it is not its own failures to set some
sort of consistent guidelines or end
goals
you know it's funny they they've done a
lot of social science study
about what encourages people to do
things and what encourages people to do
things is the notion there's an end line
if there's an end line then you tend to
do better so for example when you're
exercising
if you are running toward the one mile
mark you will tend to pick up your pays
as you get near the one mile mark
because you know that at the end of the
one mile mark that's the one-mile mark
if however somebody tells you run
indefinitely
you'll run slower because you're trying
to conserve energy because you are
because you don't know when the end line
is going to be and so it's actually very
important to set
goal posts and then once those goal
posts are hit
to move on with your life the federal
government refuses to meet the goalposts
or if they have goalposts they keep
moving the goalposts now i don't even
know where they go
they disappeared all the goalposts there
was a case we made for a goal post
that suggested don't overwhelm the
hospitals then there was a case to be
made that
put the goal post at everybody has the
opportunity to get vaccinated now the
goalposts have just disappeared
and this is just your your centralized
government boss is telling you
what you ought to do with your life and
my answer is no
my answer is absolutely not and you're
not going to tell me what to do with my
kid either
because now there is no externality to
consider
when you're talking about collective
action problems externalities are the
thing
if you can protect yourself and i can
protect myself the externality question
goes away
so i don't see what the role of
government is here okay we'll get into
more of this and the and the biden
administration
side agenda which is to social media
i'll get to that in a second first
let's talk about how you spend most of
your day you're in the office probably
you're back in the office and you're
sitting
on an office chair and you really
haven't thought about it but maybe the
reason why when you get up
in the evenings you get ready to go home
and your back is creaking your hips
don't feel good it's because your office
chair is garbage instead
get the best office chair there ever was
i'm talking about the x chair it's like
a little slice of heaven beneath your
buttocks the x chair can give you a
massage while you're sitting at your
desk
it can warm your back on cold mornings
it can cool you off on hot days
elemax temperature regulation will take
your seating comfort to a whole
new level patent pending lmx allows you
to experience cooling
heat and massage in your low back
extra's patented dynamic variable lumbar
support
was already best in class with
incredible responsive low back support
now
with lmx your comfort is guaranteed you
won't believe the difference until you
feel it
for yourself imagine regulating your
body temperature and getting massage
therapy while you are working
extra lmx delivers cooling heat and
massage technology directly to your core
regulating body temp
helping increase blood flow muscle
recovery and energy all perks that make
working from home or the office of joy
we have an extra here in the office
and the producers basically have a fight
club style fist fight every morning to
determine who gets to sit
in the extra go to xchairshapiro.com
right now that is the letter x
chair com or call one eight four four
four x chair for 100 bucks off your
order x chair has a 30-day guarantee of
complete comfort you can finance your
purchase for as little as 30 bucks a
month go to xcareshapiro.com right now
use code x wheels for free x-wheel blade
casters when you order your extra that's
ex-chair
shapiro.com for the best chair there
ever was alrighty
well we'll get back to the news in a
second first reminder i have a new book
it is coming out
next week it is a really important book
the authoritarian moment i think it may
be the most important book that i've
ever written it is all about the
takeover of the institutions you can
feel it all around you
all of the institutions from science to
education to hollywood to corporate
america
all of them are coming for you they're
coming for your freedoms you feel it i
feel but here's the thing
we can we can fix that we can stop that
in its tracks i talk about all of this
in my brand new book the authoritarian
moment now
some people collect trophies some
collect bobble heads some collect things
of actual value like signed books that
have resale value
specifically signed books by moi lucky
for you
i am signing copies of my brand new book
the authoritarian moment tuesday july
27th
as you will read there's a ton happening
right now that i predicted in the book
so you're going to want to pick up your
copy of the authoritarian moment to get
a sense of what's to come
and how we can stop it so go to
dailywire.com
ben right now order your signed copy
before tuesday's live signing and when
you do
you'll be asked to type in a question at
checkout then catch tuesday's live
signing to see if i answer your question
and watch me
sign up your book so what are you
waiting for become a part of this
exciting event and get your copy
at dailywire.com ben right this moment
also in a world that never stops
spinning there's no doubt your time is
of the utmost importance and should
never be wasted
on anything but the fact that's why the
daily wire created morning wired as the
morning podcast that values your time
and the truth we're extremely happy to
see that our listeners already
understand this because the podcast just
launched this week
it is already the number two podcast on
apple overall number 11 on spotify it is
the number one
news podcast on apple in america while
we're proud of this we need your help to
get it to number one overall
so subscribe right now to morningwire on
apple spotify or wherever you listen to
podcast leave a five star review
if you like what you hear it's brought
to you by the daily wire editor chief
john bickle i've been working with vic
for years and years he's terrific
co-host georgia howe
morningwire will wake you up with the
latest developments in politics sports
culture and education all with a heavy
emphasis on the facts in 15
bite-sized minutes perfect for your
daily commute so again subscribe to
morningwire on apple
podcast spotify everywhere you listen to
podcast so you don't miss a beat you
will be up to date on all the news that
matters in 15 minutes or less
if you like what you hear leave a five
star of you tell the podcast platforms
conservative news
belongs at number one on the charts
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
now as we've been talking about the
public health establishment has
completely failed on every messaging
level with regard
to the vaccination the reality is you
didn't really have to message this thing
mis-messaged this thing very hard
you know how i know because everybody
who's old got the vaccine
because they saw that if they didn't get
it there was a good shot they were going
to die
and so they were like okay i'm getting
the vaccine this is a really easy sell
and people take a look at the risk
factors and then they determine for
themselves what is going on
but the biden administration because
they wanted us to be all done
by now and they really don't care about
whether individual human beings choose
one way
or the other they've decided that the
real reason that there is vaccine
hesitancy is of course
because of right-wing misinformation and
because social media refused to quash
this right-wing misinformation this is
part of a broader media narrative that
has been out there for a while in which
the media push
social media to quash all dissenting
information from a bunch of different
sources right this is why npr had an
article earlier this week
openly saying that daily wire should
basically lose its traffic because daily
wear is conservative not because we lie
not because we're anti-vaxxed not
because of any of that just because they
don't like us so normally you might
expect the media right you know a first
amendment outfit
you might expect them to say to the buy
administration guys
why is it your job to tell social media
what can and cannot be distributed on
social media
but i mean this is just excellent
evidence that our media
are just the the praetorian guard for
the democratic party
they now just mirror whatever is the
narrative that the white house wishes to
purvey
so if the white house says it's social
media's fault instead of the media going
wait
the social media is a platform why is
the government trying to pressure
platforms to remove information
instead the media's like yeah social
media why don't you remove
misinformation here was nbc nightly news
just doing the same thing the white
house would do except indirectly
how does social media influence people's
relationship with facts so in our
research you know across different
countries including the united states
what we find is that when people receive
most of their
information about covert 19 and
vaccination from social media
they're more likely to be misinformed
and they're less likely
to get vaccinated versus when they get
their information from official sources
like the who or the cdc
so we actually can identify a clear link
between getting your information from
social media
and having a greater amount of
misconceptions about this issue
which in turn is linked to lower
willingness to get vaccinated
don't you see that you should be getting
all your information only from official
sources
does this sound a little bit fascistic
to you the only places you should be
able to get information
about covet maybe for anything is the
who and the cdc
except for how the who and cdc have
flipped 1 000 ways since the beginning
of this pandemic
and if you'd listened to the who at the
very beginning you wouldn't have masked
up or the cdc you wouldn't mess
up and if you listened to the who up
through about five minutes ago
the covett lab leak theory was totally
crazy and if you listen to the wh at the
very beginning
of this pandemic it wasn't even an
airborne virus covered
except for that you know it's really
only government only trusts the
government is a hell of a take from the
press
from the press these people who are like
i'm gonna hold power
to to account we're gonna we're gonna
force accountability from the powerful
make life uncomfortable for the
comfortable except
if they're of my political party in
which case i will say they ought to be
the only informational source from which
you derive information that was nbc
nightly news not the white house
amazing you see the same thing from a
columnist named will orimas over at the
washington post
has a piece titled facebook and
youtube's vaccine misinformation problem
is simpler than it seems his analysis
in the end is not that youtube and
facebook ought to just ban information
outright instead he says they should
basically just shadow ban it
much better much better they should just
change all of their algorithms so the
only things you can see are the things
that joe biden
wants you to see which of course is a
restriction on free
free determination of information
obviously that's that's what it is now
again when we get to misinformation from
the federal government
let me just point out at this point that
dr anthony fauci is misleading you right
now
okay so dr anthony fauci oversaw
the niaid which is part of the nih nih
did give grants to a place called
eco-health alliance equal health
alliance did give those grants to the
wuhan institute of virology
the hound institute of horology
performed
what is in effect gain of function
research on covet 19
or at least on on it appears on cover 19
right we don't know if it was from the
wet market
now china's saying no it is it is highly
unlikely that this was produced anywhere
but the wuhan institute of virology
and since kova 19 does not exist in bats
but now it does exist in humans it is
highly likely
that it was created through gain of
function research now that doesn't mean
that the eco health alliance grant was
specifically used to produce coven-19
it does mean that the equal health
alliance grant from the nih was used for
gain of function research in wuhan
now the slippery way out of this little
conundrum for fauci
and the nih is to claim that technically
they weren't funding gain of function
research
technically the kind of research they
were funding was just about
making animal viruses transmissible in
humans not about making it more deadly
in humans
that's a very technical distinction that
really makes no difference for purposes
of the conversation
okay the reality is that dr fauci has
been a wide
a wide and deep supporter of gain of
function research
for years and years and years because he
likes the idea that that gain of
function research
helps us fight future viruses there's a
case to be made for gain and function
research by the way there is no case to
be made the gain of function research
being done under the authority of a
totalitarian regime with no incentive
for actual health structures ought to be
funded by the united states you want to
say
fun gain of function research at harvard
go for it man you want to say
fun gain of function research in china
at the wuhan institute of virology
that's nuts okay now fouchu was called
on the carpet by rand paul for this
and fauci basically we're not funding
gain of function research we had nothing
to do with cover 19. you don't know have
you had anything to do with coven 19.
i don't know whether you had anything to
do with cover 19. what is pretty clear
is that you were not cutting off funding
for the wuhan institute of virology
which was performing exactly the kind of
research that would have led to a lab
leak if indeed this was a lab leak
nonetheless here is anthony fauci
slamming rand paul for quote unquote
slanderous commentary
i don't take any great pleasure ari in
in clashing with the senator i have
a great deal of respect for the
institution of the senate of the united
states
but he was completely out of line he
totally distorted
reality and he made some inflammatory
and i believe slanderous remarks
about lying under oath which is
completely nonsense
i mean in some of the things that he
says is so distorted and out of tune
with reality i had to call him on that i
didn't enjoy it but i had to do that
because he was completely out of line
totally inappropriate
now you may notice that dr fauci never
actually explains
what rand paul said that was overtly
false he may not like the implications
that rand paul is drawing
he may rely on this distinction between
technical gain of function research and
gain and function research on like a
broad philosophical level
but nothing that rand paul said was
actually wrong here the nih director
does the same thing again remember these
are your governmental sources you trust
them
well we're told these are the only
people you should trust here's the nih
director
defending foundry i'm very concerned
when i see
probably the most highly respected
infectious disease doctor
on the planet being treated this way
having these accusations without
any basis thrown at him stirring up all
kinds
of nasty outreaches to him that require
him now to have
24 7 security detail to protect him and
his family
what has happened to us that somebody
who's trying to help the public by
telling them the truth
is turned into this kind of demonized
character for political purposes
it is unacceptable okay i have a
question what if dr fauci is not telling
us the truth
that's the question here's rand paul
asking precisely that question yesterday
well i think it's important to know that
dr falchi has a self-interest
in obscuring any relationship or
responsibility for anything done in the
wound lab
without question the evidence we
presented in committee yesterday
shows that the nih was funding research
in wuhan
we showed the exact numerical
series of numbers that goes with the
grant number so yes they were funding
the wuhan lab but you have to realize
that dr fauci is not disinterested
if this virus came from the lab and it
becomes clear that he was funding
dangerous research
moral culpability responsibility
attaches to him and he does not want
that
okay but the bottom line is this this
really isn't about voucher generally
it's about
why should we have endless trust in a
public health establishment that has
failed us six ways from sunday
it is private industry developing the
vaccines that did not fail us the public
health experts failed us it was bad
information at every turn
in some cases they overtly lied to us
but the bite administration idea is that
only those people ought to be listened
to and we have to
just submit our own personal judgment to
the to the
tender mercies of these exact people the
answer for most americans is no
and that means it's time to get read
it's time to get back we now the
vaccines it's time to get back
to something approaching regular life
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon
is the matt wall show it airs at 1 30 pm
eastern be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel wydowsky
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
is mixed by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here editor-in-chief of the
daily wire
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode senator rand paul and
dr anthony fauci
spar over gain of function research
teachers groups gather to discuss
race and social justice and negotiations
over the infrastructure bill
appear to be wrapping up join us and get
the facts first on the news you need to
know
with our show morning wire